I'm going to say right out the gate this
question is not nearly as hard as it
looks but a lot of students just looked
at it now like no I got time for that
skip and didn't come back okay so I'm
going to walk you through this but it is
critically important one of the
dangerous things you know I don't know
if you've done this before you look at a
question you don't know how to do it so
you look at the solution you read this
through the solution and the solution
makes sense to you and you fall into the
trap of thinking oh therefore I know how
to do the question but the hardest part
of this solution is not the working
that's there it's coming up with like
looking at the question dissecting
what's important what's not important
and and then crafting that in a path
through the question so you need to
think through this quite carefully with
me so pen in hand because you're
definitely gonna need to keep up with me
as we go let's try and work out first
what do you think are the important
facts that you see in this introductory
paragraph what do you think is the first
piece information that's vital 12.5
hours is the first number that that's
sort of a thing oh I should write that
down that matters okay
12.5 hours what is the significance of
this piece of information it's the time
between successive high tides that's
what they say okay so you have to kind
of actually know Oh what does water do
it was the ocean dude right
it starts at high tide it dips down to
low tide and then it comes back up it's
a high tide so do you have a picture in
your head and you should absolutely draw
this right do you have a picture in your
head of what this tide is doing right
they've already told you it's simple
harmonic so you know it's gonna be sine
or cosine it starts from high goes down
to lower comes back up to high right and
they're telling you that the 12.5 hours
is the time between successive high
tides does that make sense so this is I
told you I wasn't sure we just go back
this is the period of motion does that
make sense
so I can say that's significance of this
figure and I'm going to pull that into
my working later on okay period so
what's the next piece of information
that's vital to think I should write
down
haitai occurs at 2:00 a.m.
haitai Decatur's Jim now I'm going to
cheat a little bit and also read a
little bit further into the question can
you see in part 1 they refer back to
that first high tide they say T is the
number of hours after high tide does
that make sense so what's T equals zero
if T is the number of hours after the
high tide T equals zero is 2:00 a.m.
it's high tired ok so I'm going to write
down all this piece of information write
T equals zero is 2:00 a.m. and that is
high time and is this make sense so you
know when we work out functions for
simple harmonic motion we have to think
about where do you begin well they've
just defined a beginning spot an initial
condition for me okay so there's my T
equals zero is there anything else in
the the introductory paragraph that I
should write down
[Applause]
yeah thank you ten meters four meters
our high tide and low tide so I'm going
to say high tide that's equal to ten
meters and I can say low tide is equal
to four meters and I think I have you
know squeezed out of this everything
that was important in the opening
paragraph lots of stuff about ships and
that kind of thing which we will turn to
later but these are the numbers that are
going to mandatory and I used to do
something specific with them
part one oh yeah all right question okay
so I will come to I'll come to the times
for low tide in a minute as it turns out
yes I could say T equals six point two
five at that well when that happens but
as you'll discover later on it doesn't
end up mattering when that is and so I'm
not going to state it I'm just literally
I'm getting out of the question all the
direct things that it says if that makes
sense yeah even though I can infer that
that's fine okay now let's have a look
at part one they give us an equation for
the water depth they really want you
this is signal by the way we really want
you to succeed in this question we are
handing this to you we even hand you
this we say show that and then they give
you a time you notice that right so even
if you can't do one well you can't do
two you can use part one and two to
progress the later parts so this is the
equation that we should land up on how
do we actually demonstrate that that's
the case okay well you see the 7 and the
3 and the 4 PI on 25 I've got to find
out from here where all of that comes
from ok so any suggestions is there a
piece of information here that I could
directly use that will help me get on
the path toward that equation we wrote
down the period first why don't we use
that ok now we know where the trig
function that the period is equal to 2
pi on it very good
that's a result that we can quote but in
fact we know what the period is I was
giving the question so I can say 12.5
equals that 2 pi on n okay this is kind
of reassuring because that 12.5 you can
see relates to the 25 that's in the
equation I'm supposed to go to write
always one iron my working and another I
on my final destination so if I multiply
through by n
and also divide through by 12.5 this is
what we have one more step and I have
that for pi on 25 that I'm trying to get
to okay so I've got my n which is going
to go at the front thumbs up okay all
right what else do I need in that
equation but I can't just state i
actually just show where it comes from
any suggestions say again
okay so there's a seven and then there's
the three okay welcome to the seven in a
second that three where does it come
from
well three the number that's at the
front of your sign of cosine function
represents the amplitude rights how far
you go okay so you can see how far I go
based on have a look at the information
that you wrote down this number and this
number you see that so I can say oh the
amplitude is halfway between your
extremes of motion right sorry not the
amplitude that's your center of motion
your amplitude is is half of the
distance between your centers of motion
so your distance between the Centers
sorry extremes of motion that's your
distance 10 take away 4 between the
extremes and the amplitude is half of
that right so 10 take away 4 is 6 6
divided by 2 that gives you your 3
that's a sad ok last piece of
information or last bit that's in the
equation anyway and I'm going to get it
from the same thing the 7 represents and
I kept saying it cuz I kept thinking it
anyway it's the it's the shift the
vertical shift which represents the fact
that the sensor information is not
actually at 0 it's halfway between those
extremes right so I can say center of
motion he's not 10-4 onto it's actually
10 10 plus 4 right I'm everything out
the two extremes now ok I'm not finding
the distance between I'm averaging them
out that gives me 7 ok and that Center
is B that's what we usually call it in
the standard way that we write this okay
yep
and yeah you could also do that same
same information different part that's
totally fine this looks really good
I've got four pound 25 I've got three
I've got seven there's one last thing
that they have given us that I haven't
accounted for yet cosine why is it
cosine and not time yeah it starts at
high tide it starts at one of the
extremes rather than starting you don't
have to draw this obviously rather than
starting at the center of motion so you
can state that in some way because this
is after all a show question right so
all I need to say is since Russian
begins an extreme right therefore it's
not starting at the origin like sine
does it's gonna start at one of the ends
I'm gonna say use cosine that's it it's
only two marks we've done a lot of work
already they don't want us to label this
point but they also don't want to pluck
it from thin air has to come from
somewhere some reason okay that's it
there's literally no more working than
to put all of these pieces together into
their equation therefore y equals if you
like you can write it in general form
first and then that's empty and then go
ahead and substitute all the values that
we have just found but your next line is
going to be their line that makes sense
so what I got seven plus there we go
happy times